una esperada financiación que llega
después de superar obstáculos de visita
en cisjordania la presidenta de la
comisión europea úrsula von der leyen
anunció que el bloque liberar a más de
200 millones de euros para paliar las
crisis humanitarias en territorios
palestinos ocupados
los fondos permanecían congelados
condicionados a cambios del sistema
educativo incluidos mensajes en los
libros escolares palestinos por ser
considerados antisemitas
es importante contar con esta
financiación de la unión europea para
apoyar a las personas especialmente a
los más vulnerados aun nuevo el acuerdo
fue celebrado por el primer ministro
palestino mohamed shtaye of europe es un
socio para la paz y la justicia en la
región hoy necesitamos una iniciativa
política para poner fin a la ocupación
detener los asentamientos y proteger los
lugares sagrados
la comisión europea es uno de los
mayores donantes a los territorios
palestinos cada año asigna cerca de 300
millones de euros hoy la ayuda es más
necesaria que nunca por los efectos de
la pandemia sumados al aumento de
precios por la guerra de ucrania
crecimiento de la violencia en el
territorio tras el encuentro la
presidenta de la comisión europea se
dirigió a israel y recorrió yad vashem
el centro de memoria del holocausto
donde reiteró su compromiso contra el
antisemitismo su presencia en la región
responde a la búsqueda de alternativas a
la importación de combustibles rusos
we decided to k hemos decidido cortar y
deshacernos de la dependencia de
combustibles fósiles rusos y alejarnos
de rusia y diversificar hacia
proveedores de confianza astros y soft
players el mismo objetivo lleva el
primer ministro italiano mario draghi a
reunirse más temprano con el primer
ministro judío
europa ahora necesita energía lo más
pronto posible e israel tiene gas
natural y estas son buenas noticias para
israel italia y europa vamos a de macael
que el cáliz draghi también visitó al
primer ministro palestino